yeah man i just finishing up my uh 18th report and uh and then i i've got to submit
six more and i'm like shut the frick up brandon was it the accent or the bug count that annoyed
you when i told you you know a little bit of both you know it makes me feel like i'm in the bin you
know best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing alrighty hackers fun little
announcement before we jump into the episode this week um brandon regret me you know you guys know
him and love him from the pod has been working with us for a long time he's been running our hacker
notes um and he's done an excellent job at that but after probably two years of working with the pod
we have decided to graduate him to a co-host in light of his massive success in the bug bounty world
lately in the live hacking events um and just going as a full-time hunter uh i think we'd like
to have him a little bit more in the spotlight and sharing his experiences so rezo isn't going
anywhere don't worry i'm not going anywhere we will have three hosts of the podcast yours truly rezo and
grep me um and we will kind of hand off from week to week but uh i just i just it's just been amazing
to see his growth as a hacker and i think he brings really good insight to the pod um so we just wanted
to welcome him on as a co-host um so yeah shoot him a dm tell him you love him he's he's doing a great
job and i'm excited to chat with him each week uh actually i think this episode that we're running
right now should have him on it so uh enjoy and uh yeah definitely send him some love all right let's go
all right hackers we got a quick this weekend bug bounty segment for you this time around um it's kind of
actually been a big week for yes we hack they just landed an eight million dollar contract with the
european commission uh becoming the new preferred bug bounty services uh provider in the eu um and i
think these sort of things as long uh in addition to what's going on in iceland with their program um the
european union we're seeing uh they're making moves in the bug bounty world and i really want that to be
successful because then other parts of the world will learn from it and do the same so um very
interesting stuff here yes we hack also recently became a uh cna which is cool um so they can issue
cves and they launched this is the opportunity i wanted to tell you guys about they launched this uh
open source uh bug bounty uh leaderboard here um there are already quite a few people rocking it on here
but if you're really into the open source scene this could be a great place to look find other hackers to
collaborate with in programs to work on all right let's go back to the show dude these these are the
weeks that we live for man am i right like these live hacking events bring i just leave these live
hacking events just brimming with with energy and passion for bug bounty oh man it's so good it's so
good you get to see your friends you get to hopefully completely crush the target and have some good
ball stories from it it is top tier stuff you just can't you can't top it yeah dude okay so let's set
the scene a little bit here um i just got back from sweden with the hacker one live hacking event
awesome you are currently crushing it in an ipc with uh is the target public for those or no i don't know
i'm not sure how many reports dude it's like 20 something reports right so i checked the stats this
morning i spoke with jay rock and he was like man you're responsible for half of the title report is
reports that's my boy yes well done man yeah yeah i i because we had our little you know i don't even
we we used to call it our mentorship meeting now you've kind of graduated from this but we had our
little sync meeting and uh and you're like yeah you know and i started one date one one freaking day
late on this competition man and you're like yeah man i just finishing up my uh 18th report and and
then i i've got to submit six more and i'm like shut the up brandon was it the accent or the bug count
that annoyed you when i said you know a little bit of both you know it makes me feel like i'm in the bin
you know um no dude but that's exciting right and so i mean what how how how bro yeah i done a little
bit of prep before the event to help myself out because it's been a while since i have actually
committed some time to hunting so a week before i really got into the event headspace i sort of done
what i could do around getting my information about some of the services that could have been in scope i
didn't know at the time um and i started looking around at the scope when it drops and i really
i have this i don't know theory of like know your target is what i refer to as when i'm trying to explain
it and i try and summarize what would hurt and where would hurt and based on what scope is available what
i can do with that so essentially what oh man i'm really trying hard not to like give any details come
on man like give us a little juice just a tiny little bit of juice well i
was fortunate enough to use a bug to gain some information from another part of the app and
although the bugs aren't changed the information was quite useful because i could deduct a lot from
what i had um say no more that is it i see okay so this is a little bit more this is a little a little
shout to the bug down metagaming here which is like when you are finding vulnerabilities and gadgets as
well you know gadgets that can leak information but um you got to keep a big picture mentality here
right it's not necessarily like you are always just gonna i find the bug report the bug and then
it's freshly and you move to the next one right sometimes you can use what you learn from those bugs
or use some of the information revealed by those bugs to inform other vulnerabilities and in fact you
should if you're looking to optimize your earnings right is that what you're saying yeah absolutely and
i just really dug deep tried to understand the threat model tried to understand
all of the apps and uh sort of got a got a bit of a feel for what i would perform well on and that's
another thing as well when you're looking at scope and you're trying to get a feel for it
try and look for your flavors of hunting on that scope and see because i doubled down i was okay i
probably would do okay here and i was right this time and dude i also done a collab with the with the
with the big dogs as well oh did you really okay yeah with the big dogs so that's that's going to be a
fun one if it comes through but well i think you messaged me right i don't know if i can dox your dms
here but like you messaged me and you're like hey man i've got this cool thing and then like i see like
two hours later i did it wasn't at my phone you're like shit you know france popped it it's like
it's like hi dang it you know like um so what was interesting i kept that conversation going or
we kept that conversation going and we actually figured out we could do some other things on another
endpoint um so we got a really nice bug out of that as well so yeah it's good but that's sorry yeah i
just i wanted to say just going back to before we moved along from your principle that you shared just
a second ago i totally think that's true in trying to align the scope to your um like capabilities and
stuff like that and figure out which app in scope is like you know you have an advantage on as a hunter
but one of the things that i've you know just consistently come back to lately is um you know i
am intimidated by a good amount of scope like desktop applications binaries some mobile stuff um you know
like just there's a good amount of that that i am afraid of and then sometimes i try to go after that
because that's where the impact is and i can see that clearly and i always am happy that i did that
you know like i i have never not been happy that i've done that and i just think that's really odd
because i feel like i should fail at that sometimes you know and i feel like i should come out with
like ah this is a little bit of a hit or miss you know like uh but really every single time i've done
it it's been like wow that was great you know yeah um i remember you saying that about a few events
actually i feel like there's two things that come into play though is really understanding the threat
model and also having a good foundation to rely on in terms of technical ability because there are a
lot of principles and concepts which will be cross-applicable regardless of what you're looking at
and i feel like you obviously have very very strong foundations to tap into so just look at whatever
man you'll find bugs you'll be fine it could be it could be it could be that yeah but i also think a
lot of other hackers are intimidated by the same things you're likely intimidated by sure and you
know they you they probably haven't had eyes on it and actually this is something that i was
thinking about recently um and i was on a run and i was thinking actually about um you know your
conversation about starting your your pen test company or whatever because you've had a lot of
inbound and i was thinking you know one of the really cool things that i would like to see some people
market um in a pen test company is a pen test company that only looks at the intimidating part of
your scope right so this is not your first pen test company this is the company that is going to
go deep and get the things that other people shied away from because they have a responsibility to do
coverage on other parts of the apps right um and and so like let's talk about a normal
pen test situation you know you hire the company they come in you've got 80 hours through the pen test
60 hours 70 hours is oh i need to cover all of the web endpoints and i need to like check them for
all of the normal stuff and you know some logic bugs or whatever right that takes up the bulk of your
time and then you know you have maybe 10 15 hours to look for these crazy deep bugs right not enough
not enough right and so they don't do it and then okay you're like okay i fix some of those things well
guess what the next guys that are going to do the next pen test they've got to go through and they've
got to do their due diligence on the same applications the same endpoints right and and you know maybe
they'll find something different because they've got a different set of eyes and a different way of
perceiving those pieces of functionality but it's unlikely that anybody is going through all of the
hoops to configure all the stuff like we see in bug bounty right like that's what why we find crazy
stuff in bug bounty is because we are digging deeper deeper and we're not confined by this by a need to
cover everything because we can cover whatever the heck we want right um and i think it would be a
really interesting differentiator for a pen test company to say hey listen we're gonna ignore all of the
basic scope some give it to the other pen test companies okay we are just going to go for the
stuff that's very deep and very technical in your app and and you know spend time there we may not find
anything but we may find something that breaks the whole world you know for sure so sort of like
a flavor of red teaming but for web apps and that sort of hardcore like in the weeds type research
yeah i think it could be very good and we see some of this stuff with like cure 53 and stuff like that
right where they're they're going super deep on stuff but i i i don't know that they're putting it
in their marketing material that it's like hey listen we're not going to find your access control bugs
you know like it's not going to happen we're going to focus on this you know yeah no that's an
interesting thought i feel like there would be a lot of appetite as well for some of the bigger
security companies that want that to go through their budget to improve and also for actual bug bounty
companies as well before adding new scope to in program that's exactly what they would want to do
let's let's talk about that after yeah yeah like why why are we doing this on air um yeah okay all
right um anyway let's get to the actual content of the app oh wait no no i didn't even get to talk
about my life hacking yeah so how how did your stuff go i heard from somewhere you might have done very
well from yeah dude frick i let me check right now because i think they're still paying out some of the
stuff i'm still as of the recording this in first place just barely sliding above the uh the team that
get uh guys um which is amazing um but yeah man it was a great event um this one was in sweden which
is actually one of my top places in the world to go and um i i found a couple um good bugs that i was
actually able to get escalated to criticals because of um some nuances in their threat model
um that would not traditionally be criticals um and so that was good and then yeah man just sat down and
pumped pumped it out on a very difficult piece of scope and found you know the the super crit that that
you need to like seal a good event right because i feel like um you know just going back to the live
hack event strategy thing i feel like if you want to crush it at an event you've got to have like good
performance across the board you know get your mediums in there get your highs in there get get you
know one crit two crits and then one mega crit right that kind of seals the deal at least you know
if you get one mega crit that's like oh no like this is the end of the world then that that really
solidifies the event for you so that's what i was going for so i wanted to talk to you about that
because there's this i've had it in a few of the other events and i'm really digging deep to try and
find something obscure it's taken me a bunch of time i enter panic's not the right word but like this
mindset of oh no i'm not reporting something do i do i go for volume or do i go deep in this do you
experience at all and how do you combat that because it almost blocks my ability to go really
deep in the weed sometimes and it's very frustrating yeah i think it i think i do and i think that was
something i struggled with more earlier in my life i came at career but still struggle with and that is
why you know in the beginning i spent a lot of time and just like you did this event i was so hyped when
i heard you say this because i'm like that's that's my guy um but you know going for volume trying to get
a feel of these applications right um getting a decent amount of base reports in and then you've
already done you know a good amount of uh you know like looking into a specific app right and and i
would say volume in a in a specific app like i would really not endorse jumping from app to app to app to
app i would say volume and a specific app and then and then you know after the duke window closes or
after you feel like you've got a good base of reports or understandings then kind of shooting your
shot for those deeper those deeper bugs right um yeah but yeah i i think i often i've done that post duke
window the con of this approach is that sometimes the mega crits that people find right off the bat
will get fixed and you'll miss them you know yeah i mean it's again finding the strategy that works for
you fundamentally because different people like there's a few lhe hackers that run their game in a
way which would just give me a meltdown a lot that i can't do this yeah um so again i think it just
comes back to as you said that experience and finding your flow because everyone looks for different bug
classes different bug classes require varying context of the application bearing understand and
it's all unique i guess is my point it is it is man it's a it's a very unique ecosystem it's a good
it's a good thing that we've got variety too and and i think some hackers just don't give a lily and
they show up and they hack whatever they want to hack and i think that's cool you know uh but i think
yeah and and and to some degree i aspire to that but i also aspire to really consistently performing
at these live hacking events and i think um that my methodology and the methodology you implemented
here i think is one of the most reliable ways to reliably perform right and yeah and whereas you'll
see some people that knock knock mega crits on day two at some events and then don't find anything at
other events yeah 100 i feel like we might have to edit that out because that's a very valuable meta
strategy yeah that people are going to use against us yeah well you know hey that's that's the give and
take of the pod man hike i i especially lately i've been realizing like dang like some of the stuff that
i that we distribute on the pod stings sometimes when it comes back to to like be used against you in a
competition dude the one of my most prized gadgets that i use in so many chains that i mentioned on my
first pod episode has been patched since that went out and i only noticed this like two weeks ago what is
it maybe three weeks ago um it was the on the target that i look at quite often in a certain part of the
right ecosystem the owl um mode where you can force a redirect yeah just without sort of like it's just
by design but they've patched it and it completely i was getting so excited i thought i've got something
just for this and then nothing i was like i shouldn't have said it on the pod i just should have just left it
yeah yeah and sometimes and like we discussed before this episode you know you do have to kind
of watch the things you say because these companies do like especially the companies that we're talking
about under you know i guess behind the scenes a little bit right now all they all listen to the
podcast you know and so it's like all right but um but yeah it's part of it it is it is and it's a part of
the give and take of the industry as well we are standing on the shoulders of giants in so many ways you know um
and so yeah i guess it's a part of the game before we move on i did want to talk about some of your
takeaways because you have some very unconventional pieces of wisdom in here uh which i'd like you to
double double click on so i want to i want to be clear about this um these takeaways are a mix
of um experiences from this last live hacking event and from talking to other hackers at the live hacking
event about their experiences at lhe's and in hacking over the past like couple couple weeks now um or a
couple months i i want to disclaim here i always get people's permission before i share these these
things so don't do frickers come up to me and be like oh can't tell justin anything because he's gonna
yap about it on the pod i always get permission before i talk about something on the pod um so anyway
with that being said here are a couple fun takeaways okay um one sometimes you fight with a laugh okay and
that is a very unpleasant experience and most of the time we win our battles with laughs um it's just
persistence it's encoding it's understanding quirks of the system uh it's you know stripping or sanitization
that occurs on the back side of the laugh right all of those things can lead you to bypassing laughs
uh or contextually aware laughs as well you know trying to abuse that um yeah the problem is sometimes
they've just got like a includes rule and they just auto deny and it's like there's nothing you can do
you know um and so one of the hackers i was speaking with i had a situation like this uh
and they were saying that the way that they actually ended up uh exploiting it was internal employees
for this company are not routing through the waf they their dns internally resolves to directly to
the host so um while all of the users of the company you know were hitting cloudflare akamai or whatever it
was um when an employee clicked to the link it would it there was no laugh in front of it and the bug would
pop right um and in the specific context the guy was telling me about uh it like the internal employees
were one of the prime targets for this bug and they had a delivery mechanism through the business logic
right so it was just like perfect storm and uh and but i i hadn't really thought about that before
so i wanted to shout that out and i also just don't have really any good ideas on how to test whether
this is possible without actually like having a contact at the company yeah it's tough because
those sort of context switches are what you'll only really see when you're looking at say like blind
xss bugs typically isn't it because they're being detonated from a different context in terms of how man
you'd need some serious threat modeling and guessing i think in order to get to that and you'd also need
the bugs to line up in the sense that you actually can deliver a canary or some description to even
test it so i'll say it's definitely rarer from what i can think yeah i'm thinking as well like
blind xss is is an interesting point you know you could definitely test it with a blind xss
um if you're just looking for if you have a blind xss and you are trying to do what you were saying
like use the bug to gain more information about your target which is a little bit red teamy a little
bit pivoty but you know ask forgiveness rather than permission there sometimes um but i was also
thinking when you said that actually maybe this could be a good use for blind ssrfs is if you've got
like a like a only status code blind ssrf what you could do is try to hit an asset from that blind ssrf
in uh you know that's a public facing asset from within the com the company and it you know put a
malicious uh string let's just do like your normal script alert right in the creeper rams and if it hits
that server and doesn't give a 403 then you're not getting blocked by the waft right uh but if it
does then you know that you are routing through the waft yeah so that's good interesting interesting
thing you could potentially use a blind ssrf to kind of give you some intel about the company for
that's good that's good but that comes with its own caveats of you don't actually know the segment
you are calling out from internally and what that looks like but it's still a potential gadget
nonetheless yeah it doesn't say that it it's not the case but if it works then you do know that it
is the case exactly yeah it's like a yeah that's some big brain stuff that's like some i know there's
some like logical like if a is b and b is c then a is c or whatever like thing that i can do there but
i i can't wrap my head around it while i'm talking yeah don't look at me mate i i can't do that on the
spot either give me 10 minutes and i might be have to say um okay so that's takeaway number one sir can
circumvent waft sometimes um with for internal employees not routing through you know uh external
dns um number two secondary context bugs i've always struggled with exploiting um and i've done it
you know a dozen couple dozen times probably but i i just whenever i look at them unless it's really
verbose and it's really just dumping back exactly what's happening on the backend um api sometimes i
really struggle with it because it's like um you know they're expecting a certain format in the json
structure of the response and sometimes you're getting partial fields back and sometimes you're not
getting anything back and it's like uh um one one tip that i did get from a hacker at this live hacking
event um and they actually showed me the bug from a couple months ago that they exploited was that
secondary context bugs um can also be exploited to bypass access controls within a like our back
environment which is very interesting like sometimes what you'll see in a in apps is that um you know
they've got maybe like your organization id or your account id or whatever in the url right and if
you try to mess with that at all you're done you're cooked right like it just has to be there as a
part of the path um for the api and that's where all their access controls are done um but sometimes
that's done by a front-end service so if you have a secondary context path traversal um you may be able
to uh you know provide a organization or an account id in the path that you own right so that you're an
admin on but then you're also in a different organization where you're just a lower privileged
user and then overwrite that on the secondary on the secondary context traverse back up and then and
then uh go build out the whole path again i hope that makes sense but um you know i i just almost
always thought about this from the context of like um cross-org attacks and i think obviously that's where
you should go first but if you're really stumped on cross-orgs attack definitely try to exploit um
same org our back implementation uh and see make sure that extends past the first proxy into the
secondary api as well that oh this is so painful because there's so much i want to talk about but i
can't from this event but that exact scenario is i'm working with something now and i've been testing
this theory all morning um hopefully i can talk about next time but yeah it's very good way to look
at things because once you start getting those sort of gadgets it can turn something which was weird
behavior into a really really nice bug just by thinking about architecturally where are those
access controls implemented and if you can get a device error or something like that to disclose that
as well which i may or may not have done somewhere oh just i'm gonna stop talking okay dude yeah it's
crazy because i mean the bug that the guy showed me it's it's on a different target than the one you're
working on and it's interesting that we're seeing this this is when you know you're giving good tips
guys this is you know this is what's so exciting to me about critical thinking now is i love it when
we get to talk about stuff like this and i know that many top tier hackers are listening to this being
like ah i'm gonna change my methodology because of this you know that's our north star with critical
thinking is and even with you coming on as the as the co-host which by the way after we started i
decided i'm gonna record a preempt to this episode and explain that so okay they already know about
that okay good um but uh yeah i mean it's you know one of the north stars that for the podcast is
making sure that elite hackers you know intermediate to advanced level hackers are getting a takeaway every
single week that modifies their methodology that makes them be a better hacker right if we're doing just
one of those every week then we're winning right absolutely um and so yeah absolutely let's just
hope we don't do for many of these bugs now yeah dude shocks yeah okay um all right last one i'll keep
this one brief i don't know this is something that i i mean i was in sweden so i was hanging out with
with franz and matias and these guys are just legendary and um and i i always leave conversations
with them thinking like man i do not theorize what's happening in the back end pipe pipelines nearly as
much as i should you know and especially in an environment when you're working with an amazing team
and and you can have a conversation with them about like hey is this what's going on in your back end or you
know whatever like um uh it just opens my eyes to like oh yeah that is a very logical deduction that
i could have made from a black box perspective and i just need to start flexing those muscles a little
bit more that is exactly it i recall there was a time at some point last year when i messaged you
after franz dropped a crazy bug and i was like what have you done this week to think more like franz
when you're approaching a target and i remember messaging you like four times but yeah i think he's
the best example of it when the research on the do you remember the headers when he's like shelled
through the ie identity or the request id either like uh logging headers yeah that is like the perfect
research if you haven't seen it go and check out the old hacker notes because that is like the perfect
highlight of using that what can we deduct from a black box scenario perfect of exactly that and it's just
insane one of the one of the things i've realized from this too from from talking to franz and matthias
though is that like matthias is i mean we i've highlighted matthias many times on this podcast
because of the amazing hacker that he is but he continues to be underrated man like
matthias is is every bit like as as good at that as franz is and and you just don't hear about it quite as
much i feel like he doesn't make as much content though compared i might be wrong on that we're
fixing that though okay we are i like i i've i sent him a mic for the pod like and and to be honest
man i've used his archive alchemist tool a bunch we talked about on the pod he covered it in an episode
super good tool and really really excellent for finding critical vulnerabilities and guys like if you
haven't watched that episode go back and watch that episode whenever you're you actually have the
opportunity to test an archive upload okay because um i did that recently when i was testing some stuff
and i had such a blast with it and i got some really impactful stuff out of it and um now i feel
excuse me so much more comfortable with that tool you know and i've got muscle memory for it i know
exactly what it can do and and now that i've done it at least once testing the whole methodology that he
outlined in that episode i just feel like i've got a grip on it now and i will not shy away at all
from archive related vulnerabilities moving forward i will run to them you know because i've got the tool
and the methodology to to exploit them yeah man i've been waiting i really have been waiting but nothing
as of yet so i'll keep an eye out and hope something cool comes up keep an eye out man um all right
that's what i had for my live live hacking events uh you know chats and takeaways um let's uh let's get
into some news content shall we first up on the news um actually we've got gareth hayes dropping stuff
as always um and this one was particularly interesting i thought y'all because um he's using this
attributes uh for those of you that are on youtube you can you can check it out but he's um using the
attributes um reference inside of an html um on on event handler so he's got input on focus and then
attributes zero dot value so he's reassigning the first attribute of the specific html element which is
in fact the on focus that he's presently in um and then uh reassigning what javascript should be run
uh uh upon execution of this uh uh function here um and then he uses that to smuggle data in from
the uh hash which is can contained in the url um reference uh and redefine what the actual
uh javascript is being run when that on event handler occurs so i know that's a little bit a little bit
dense there but the the main takeaways here that i think the hunter should have is that if you need
to smuggle data maybe you've got like a specific character set that you can't get past because this
is pretty character set liberal you can reassign attributes inside of uh your html element so input
on focus or whatever um using the data from the url um reference which is only valid inside of an html tag
uh very brilliant approach here by by gareth and i did have a little demo um do you understand what
i'm saying grab me or is this just like yeah so for me like i'm looking at you saying these words
and i get like one fifth of the context before my brain goes nope and then i get the other one first
okay okay look at this look at this lab really great because he linked this lab as well okay so the
on click for this input is attributes zero so the first attribute dot value equals um you know backtick
plus url plus backtick okay so essentially it's saying hey take the current url stick it inside of
the first attribute which is the on click uh and put it inside of template literals the backticks right
so then what you do is when you click it look at it look what happens now it takes the current url
stick is sticks it inside of backticks right and then um from the hash you grab the dollar sign
curly brackets alert one which allows you to execute code inside of the template literal right and then
when you click it again you get the pop right so it's priming the data in the hash um with dollar
sign curly brackets alert one right and then it's using the attributes zero dot value to pr to take
the data from the url stick it inside of the the on event handler and then when you trigger it it it
triggers the the actual code that's in the url to be run right so does he just set out his desk and
guys you know what i think this might work and then he just writes that and it works like how i think
he does dude i think he actually does do that like i see some of these things on a scrolling on twitter and
i actually i laugh out loud because i just think how has someone just concocted that and everything he
posts is just so good it's freaking good man and and i will say for those of you that are not like
client-side like loving client-side stuff if you are you should definitely be
investigating this but if you don't your major takeaways here are using the attributes reference
to redefine attributes on your current html tag and then um knowing that url the string url all caps
is a way to reference essentially the document uri um in only when you are inside of an on event handler
doesn't it reference something else when you're outside of an on event yeah exactly so if you just type url it
typically it's a fun it's like a it's like a type right it's a constructor but if you're actually
doing it inside of the the function um inside of like a on click event or something like that
then okay well i didn't update it now but yeah you can see right here that's the the document url
right nice right nice cool stuff yeah he is he his brain needs to be preserved and studied it's just like
one of those things where crazy crazy content continuously as well i'm with you i'm with you
definitely port swigger research they've got some amazing stuff coming out they do on that note
huli he's had a lot of love on the pod they i should say on the pod before um is back with some more
research which will help you digest some of that gareth hayes magic um really really good write up good
blog and what i love about this and really warms the heart upon opening if you have any thoughts on my
blog and articles you want to let me know you can either post a comment or tell me via this feedback form
they are actively looking for feedback from the community is that not like such a nice thing
has a feedback form on their free blog dude that is that's just crazy like that is so nice of them
that is such a commitment to quality yeah yeah so good um anyway the actual blog itself does a really
nice job of breaking down some of these more exotic payloads that you might see and exactly how some of
these tag template literals work oh yeah yeah exactly just like we were talking about just a second ago
exactly why they work and some of the context that would be useful for them to actually work in which
i thought was really good um i know again we've mentioned so much of their research on the blog before
but i really really like the way they break down every single subject give you every single topic and
give you some of the applicable use cases as well and just a really nice uh writing style which i've
grown an appreciation for since the hacker notes i must admit yeah well dude i mean i love this one that
you've got on the screen right here which is you know on error equals eval and then throw equals alert
one like that's so fun like it's just being able to use those error handlers and then the throw keyword
it really allows you to get around some some character restrictions yeah it's like using your error
message as a uh as a payload but then they just keep breaking down these payloads and how you can
further eliminate syntaxes that might be giving you a problem um really nice useful if you have if you're
being blocked by a waft for example very useful if you're not as comfortable with client-sized stuff
like me like this is the perfect content um and it probably builds upon some of gareth hayes's
content in his javascript for hackers book which i have committed to myself to read end-to-end
i always get part of the way through and i'm like this is some heavy stuff and never commit to it
i will commit to it i will do it yeah and then that is definitely one of the the seminal works you
know and in making you a a good client-side hacker 100 and then the thing i did want to give a shout out
is like they give a like the mother payload at the end this absolute i want to call it a monstrosity but
it isn't it's like art um just look at that and it only works in chrome and again such a good job of
breaking it down exactly how it's working and yeah they've got they've got this is without quotes it looks
like wow yeah yeah they've they've abstracted away the quotes with uh you know decimal representation
of strings and then forcing a conversion with a uh looks like with a regex there that's uh that's
pretty sick bro honestly it's just insane so hats off to them because every piece of content they put out
is just like so in depth so in the weeds and overall really good read and then they give you a few key
points at the end commas can chain multiple expressions returning the last one replacing the on
error with eval allows you to execute the error messages code errors thrown will become part of the
error message and as long as you can turn the error message into valid code you've succeeded dude that i i love
that those four at the end there that's that's really good okay i'm gonna say them again commas can
chain multiple expressions returning the last one that's pivotal because uh you often will want to
control the return value while getting something done right replacing on air with eval allows you to
execute the error messages code that's a really good one errors thrown will be a part of the error message
itself so converting the error message into valid code and then as long as you can do that you are
avoiding syntax errors in getting uh your your payload through yeah dude i feel like you should get that
as like a tattoo like the quote on your arm for being the client side that's beautiful man for um you know
syntax or um uh character set restricted environments this is like the new go-to yeah and they give you
a lot of that context throughout the blog post as well i can't think see where it is but exactly where
it'd be useful might be useful so worth a read for you guys which aren't as handy on the client side
as um as like me really yeah good good stuff man um pivoting a little bit from uh well actually you
know what tell you what we'll we'll uh we'll stick with the client side um stuff for just a second longer
uh and i'm not going to spend too much time and dwell on this one because um it's not strictly relevant
to hacking uh but there is an amazing um amazing write-up here of google's safe content frame
and if you are at all interested if any of the listeners here i know a lot of you guys have
absec jobs if your requirements for your company require you know you to render an arbitrary html file
that is very hard to do in a safe way um and you know preserve isolation of code uh isolation of
your domain right because we can set cookies up to the top level domain um very difficult problem to
solve i have spent a lot of time trying to crack safe content frame that google has produced to fix this
problem and uh it's it's bulletproof man like it is really really um and so if you're interested in
understanding how exactly all that works um you can see how it works here they combine uh a a isolated
domain with uh and a public suffix list uh registration with um delivery via iframe that checks event source
and um blobs and uh this is the key part right here the hashing of the content uh and the parent origin
um to create a unique subdomain of these domains uh which makes it impossible for you to even like
you can't affect the code because the parent origin changes and if the code changes at all inside of it
then it changes the hat so it's like this is painful um but really really well done by the google team and
this is i think the go-to solution if you have to render untrusted html inside of your app is this a
new thing or has this been around for a while and they've just improved upon it it's it's been around
for a while this is the first write-up i've seen that like fully explains the it from the engineering side
but there have been a lot of ctfs run on it because the google team is like hey hack this you know um
and yeah it's pretty freaking bulletproof and i know that tara jank uh who was mentioned in the uh
last article you you had up um was one of the main engineers for this uh and it's just it's freaking
good dude it's really really good well have the client side guys got their hands on that jorian and
co in the channel i'm sure they have yeah yeah i mean i i we've talked about it before and i mean
it's just there's there's just not much there's like it painfully uses the right structure i mean
that hashing that creates the unique domain and you know having the public suffix list
there's nothing you can do like that just completely isolates everything um so one of those normal ones
will it pain you as much as the coop pad is did um i don't know man troop is coop is the worst coop
coop is like really uh a pain in my butt um the thing is even even if you can get a frame reference
to this thing dude which is a problem in and of itself uh yeah there's just nothing there's no attack
surface so yeah yeah i i spent so much time i was like you know what guys i'm gonna i'm gonna assess
this the the tergic was over there laughing like all right bro like take a stab at it and i'm like
nothing yeah yeah actually i will say i did find a problem with the implementation of it somewhere
though uh in in google's uh infrastructure so well that's something yeah there's nothing wrong with
this itself but the way that they took this and implemented it was not spec and so i was i was able
to do something there oh there you go you're fine then um good stuff i think the next one i'd want to jump
in on is a very very good write-up on microsoft entra let me just share my screen um and there's a
the reason why i did want to cover it because the depth that this thing goes into is just insane
and yeah one token to rule them all obtaining global admin in every entra id tenant via actor tokens
geez honestly the reason i wanted to cover this is because we've used the term megacrit on the pod
before and this is literally an unstoppable megacrit that they could have done nothing about because
there's no detection for it um so if people aren't familiar microsoft entra is essentially
uh azure ad but the newer version rehashed and it's pretty much their cloud identity service
um so it can be quite the target for a lot of red team assessments and the whole crux of the problem is
essentially you have i'll dive into the impact in a minute i just want to give some context
you have these things called actor tokens which are used by some services to essentially imitate a user or
service and do so with god-like permissions in the sense that you can use the service but not actually
you be the user that initiated it um so it also uses the microsoft graph api and azure ad graph api
which is somewhat applicable to bug bounty because bug bounty programs are run on both of them as well
and this is the sort of content that will help you attack those apis perfectly um so the overview of the actor tokens is that
they were essentially tokens issued by the access control service and this guy didn't know what the
service was but he guessed that it was a legacy thing used by sharepoint applications and uh if you've
ever had an encounter with sharepoint you know it's it's pretty awful it's pretty yeah pretty bad always
always a bad time exactly i was a sharepoint admin for uh that was my first like real job in it was
being a sharepoint and i did not stay in that job for very long yeah no wonder you went to bug bounty so
quickly mate that exactly that's tough um anyway the whole way this finding came about is that he was
examining an exchange flow and in this exchange flow in a hybrid setup
essentially exchange would request an actor token
um when it wants to communicate with another service now the as i said earlier the actor
token allows it to imitate
that service or user that it's using and this is the the overview of the token um for listeners it is
a jwt um but a lot of the claims are good so they look like absolute nonsense and unless you were really
deeply rooted into the ecosystem you probably wouldn't have any idea what any of these correspond to
but luckily this guy is so far embedded into this ecosystem he knew everything
um so i'd love to see it man love to see that that this is why i had to give this a shout out because
so many good pieces of information in this and the breakdown um and essentially
the audience and all the claims uh doids for what you're requesting and the main thing here which is
actually readable is the trusted for delegation value which is true and that is what allows the actor
token to be an actor token now in the next part of the flow of this exchange functionality you're looking
at exchange would embed the token that we just covered in into an unsigned jwt which is then sent to
the resource provider which was uh azure graph now essentially they've taken a wraps token which was signed
and then placed it in a completely unwrapped um sorry unsigned jwt my bad but they are using values from
the unsigned jwt to make um assumptions or decisions based on the authentication of that user
now don't know why they've done that but we'll carry on why did they do that the world will never know
yeah why they've done that who knows um now in the unsigned jwt you have a name id which is originates
from the azure ad graph api um and more importantly you have the where is it the
no upn no that one doesn't matter for now um
now these impersonation tokens especially all these claims specify the service you want to impersonate
and none of them are signed so once exchange has that token it can use it to impersonate anyone
against the target service it requested um for 24 hours by the way now this is hilarious because
this is taken directly from the blog it lacks almost every security control you would want there's no
you can't don't skip the line before that in my personal opinion this whole actor token design is
something that should never have existed go ahead it lacks almost every security control you'd want
there's no logs when acts tokens are issued since these services can craft unsigned impersonation
tokens without talking to entra there are no logs when they are created or used they cannot be provoked
they completely bypass any restrictions configured in conditional access and we have to rely on logging
from the resource provider now this is just absolutely insane that these sort of things are kicking about
in the yeah ecosystem and this next screenshot is really sums it up so you have the signed actor token
but then the unsigned jwt is what's actually being used for some of the impersonation
and that is unsigned which you can just put whatever in send it off providing you have that signed
actor token wow so okay so yeah that's really weird it looks like we're for the audio listeners we're looking at
the breakdown of a jwt so you see the header right in the close parentheses and then you're looking at the
body and you see inside of that jwt a field called actor token which contains a signed jwt but then you
also see following that a bunch of fields that you would expect to see in the in the jwt aud iss etc
and these this is an unsigned token and then i guess it's using those values from the unsigned jwt rather
than the signed jwt inside of the unsigned jwt is that am i representing that right yeah exactly that
so you've got two different checks being performed you've got the first check which actually gives you
the actor token to make sure it's valid and you're requesting something valid but then they go ahead and
wrap that in an unsigned jwt and make assumptions based off of what you want to assume on the unsigned
jwt okay okay brendan let me let me ask you this here i'm sorry to interrupt because i know this is a
complex bug but i think what might be a good like global takeaway here for us is that if we see a jwt that
contains another jwt look at the the fields that are shared between the two because i i mean i could
totally see how this would happen right essentially they are looking at the top level jwt instead of
the embedded one and all they needed you know to maybe to fix their code even was you know dot here
scroll up a little bit what's the name of that yeah dot actor token dot aud right rather than dot a ud
so if there's any embed and then overlap in the body of those jwt tokens that could be a really good
area for us to test absolutely and i feel like as well this blog for me summarizes perfectly when
you're looking at a target with so many interconnected and interacting services that depends on another
service to performance authentication for example and completely trust that that is the absolute truth
there's so much gold in that man especially when you have two different apis kicking around like one
of these apis is actually only there and being phased out and it's there for backwards compatibility
issues and there's been so many bugs come off the back of it and yeah like the whole write-up very
very good it covers the practical abuse this is exact impact it could basically use a token from its own
tenant to go cross tenant and impersonate anyone using publicly available ids of which aren't even though
they are guids in some instances they're not secret you can retrieve them and if you've ever looked at
any of the azure or microsoft bug bounty program you will know that there are so many ways to disclose
some of this information i know quite a few hunters yeah dude it says okay find the net id of a regular user
craft the impersonation use that impersonation to list all global admins on the tenant
and get their net id and then impersonate those and then do whatever the heck you want
that's nasty man that's super nasty crazy and if you are thinking about attacking some of these services
start off with this blog because it gives you exactly where and how to find some of these
net ids and even some of the impacts of the threat model when you are looking at cross tenant into
tenant and also abusing the actual apis and we could talk about this right up for about an hour so
i will try and wrap it up because there is so much content packed into here but the last thing i did want
to cover they've got detections and everything like that is this last bit here the very last part of the
blog i do not have access to any tenants in the national cloud deployment so i was not able to test
whether the vulnerability existed there since national cloud deployments use their own uh token signing
keys it's unlikely that would have been possible to execute this attack from a tenant in the public
cloud to one of these national clouds i do consider it likely that this attack would have worked across
tenants in the same national cloud deployment that level of understanding and expertise on a service
is like master level and whenever this person now brings out a blog or any content about entra as your
graph or anything related i will trust them absolutely because you don't get this this sort of information
just by playing around these things you spend a serious amount of time to understand that yeah dude i'm
gonna just click on their x directly from uh this article and yeah dang it i'm not following them i've
been missing out i'm gonna turn on notifications that's pretty sick yeah so good man so yeah i love
that you read that little little line this is like a grayed out line at the very bottom in the like
subnotes as well brandon at the bottom so props to you for for being very thorough in your assessment of
uh this write-up and i think that also is a is a vote of confidence you know to hear this researcher
say that for me in in sort of um nation segmented cloud environments right where you know you'll have
like you know us government aws or whatever or you know that sort of thing sort of segmented off i was
like uh yeah in the past have been like okay that might be a little bit overboard you know bureaucracy
saying okay everything's got to be segmented but it's cool to see that such an impactful vulnerability
like this actually you know it was limited by that sort of nation-based cloud segmentation if i'm
understanding what he's saying correctly yeah yeah absolutely and i feel like it sums up perfectly once
you have so much context and some of these serve um services you can really dig deep into the threat
model to the extent that you can understand whether deployment locations and these more segregated environments
would be affected by knowing that they'll use their own token signing keys like for honestly hats off to
this guy it's very commendable the depth and level of research that they've done on this one very very
good totally man totally that's uh d-i-r-k-j-a-n-m dot io so definitely check that out if you guys want
to um add that to like your rss list or whatever um next up a little bit lighter uh we've got flareprox uh
fireprox is actually one of the tools i use very often uh despite that episode with uh with um uh ryan from
uh you know akamai saying like hey justin that's illegal don't do that that fixes the terms and uh
and services or whatever um so anyway if you're looking to not do that then do it through cloudflare
with flareprox um and get you know essentially for those of you that aren't familiar with it essentially
this abuses um sort of ephemeral cloud environments like workers and um i guess like you know api gateway
in the aws one um to get you new ips for every single request so if you're dealing with a uh strong
amount of rate limiting and you really need fuzz then you're gonna want to use fireprox or flareprox to
do that um and that is uh this one is is popped up um that uses the cloud flare ip space to avoid
detections and blocks yeah and the code looks pretty solid i mean i will say one that that's a little bit
weird with this i know that fireprox gives you um a unique domain for each host that you want to fuzz
it looks like this one actually just allows you to specify a url equals in your um like queer parameter
of your target right so it's like this one there might be some weird encoding stuff with that or some
weird gotchas there um so i would keep an eye out for that uh and it certainly i mean it looks like
it's passing through all your put and posts and all that sort of thing but it does allow you to be a
little bit more flexible as you can keep that worker up and use it to scan multiple different hosts if you
want so yeah more importantly absolutely do not host that on a very guessable domain or something you
use a lot because if that's url equals and it accepts anything i'll dig into the code later but that that's
right for abuse so yeah be careful on that front as well yeah i think there's sort of a spin up spin
down as you as you do you know thing but that's true if you forget to spin it down that could be
that could be you know you could be paying for a lot of people's group forces out there
yeah i feel like as well now we're starting to get to the point where a lot of these ecosystems like
when fireprox got released right aws was really i think off the top of my head one of the only
ecosystems that supported it with the api gateways we're now seeing a lot of other providers mature up
and to the point that they have like a competitor service offering so now you've got these tools coming
out and when you combine it with um asset notes newtowner you go right okay i'm accessible from
cloud flares ip range or i'm accessible for aws i've got that test sorted let's just spin one up
here and you can have a lot of fun with that i think so it's quite nice to see how it's all playing
out over time now that we're just bypassing all these silly defenses that people are putting out yeah
yeah and and i mean there's definitely a little gray area with the you know agreements or terms of
services with these but hackers gonna hack so yeah well we'll get our accounts banned but yeah and i
when that came up on the episode i was like okay you saw i guess you have to say that as an employee
but come on man no one a motivated attacker will not give an absolute hell about that yeah and that's
what i told him too i was like look man we're all on the same side here you know like as much as it
feels like maybe sometimes we aren't we are you know um so yeah i think i yeah i agree no 100 um how are we
doing on time are we okay yeah we're good um let me let me just uh i'll i'll do this next one real quick
and then we'll wrap it that cool sure okay so um just wanted to give a shout out because uh i too below
who is an excellent hacker um a did a write-up recently um on kaido 101 and if you read his blog which
i do and all of you guys should as well um he credits his shift to kaido i think with a lot of
growth for him as a hacker as somebody who was um you know previously up and coming in the space and i
think now is pretty confirmed uh top tier hacker um and so he was talking about his shift to kaido
and he wrote this kaido 101 how to master it right up um and he breaks down uh coming from burps and
friction points you might see um cli versus desktop breaks down all the various sections of the kaido
application understanding concepts like hpql workflows plugins uh etc um so if any of you guys are
looking to take the deep dive on kaido and are looking to be led to the light so to speak uh i'm
looking at you brandon uh then this could be a good read for you guys just kind of understand exactly
how to do that nice yeah these sort of resources i feel like when you're very much stuck in your ways
like i have been in birth for forever those are the sort of resources you want to find just to understand
the capabilities what you can do and on that note the kaido scope i've messaged you
about it during that event but man please can that get changed really fast it is so kaido kaido
um has a public issue tracker okay you can go to the roadmap and one of the items on the roadmap
right now is is try to adjust the scope to be a little bit more compatible with hacker expectations
oh man i will i will fund my hard-earned british pound coins to get that implemented into the tool
if i have to i need it because it was giving me a few problems in this event it's
i guess because of the current transition over yeah man it to be honest like i get it
but i use filters and it just works you know like that's what i use and and it works fine so it is a
little bit of a friction point it's definitely not as intuitive but there are there is a solution you
know you can do path-based filtering and very granular filtering on what you want to see in http
history using filters other than scope but that right there is the key what you just said you can
use http filters now there's a lot of extensions which solely rely on the scope so your extension is
absolutely hammered with everything when because i've seen this mismatch because i did have a filter
on but then my extension was going haywire and i was thinking what is going on and it's because it uses the
scope so yeah interesting all right good good feedback man i'll bring that to the team right
after this episode awesome i'll fund it as well to get pushed out okay i'll let them know thanks man
all right that's a wrap that's the pod peace peace and that's a wrap on this episode of critical
thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if
you want to support the show head over to ctvb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots
of great high-level hacking discussion happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive
content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me i'll see you there